comme prévu l'europe est officiellement
entrée en récession ce jeudi 30 avril il
s'agit de la pire récession depuis le
premier calcul de la croissance annuelle
par l'insee dans les années 1940
en france même en mai 68 les chiffres
étaient meilleurs au premier trimestre
de cette année folle le pib a chuté de
près de 6%
il faut remonter à 1940 pour assister à
un tel plongeon
car de nombreux secteurs sont touchés
restauration tourisme événementiel ou
encore aéronautique sont les plus
impactées par une crise qui aura des
conséquences à long terme
comme annoncé en mars dernier par le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
des baisses de chiffre d'affaires de 60
% en moyenne pour les créateurs de 30 à
40% dans l'hôtellerie de 25% en moyenne
pour les restaurateurs et des chiffres
encore plus fort pour tout le secteur de
l'événementiel puisque les animations se
font aujourd'hui en cascade
il y aura un avant et un après
cette épidémie de coronavirus sur
l'organisation de l'économie mondiale et
que nous voyons bien dans un certain
nombre de secteurs à quel point il est
important de réfléchir à une meilleure
organisation des chaînes de valeur à une
relocalisation de sion d'un certain
nombre d'activités stratégiques en
particulier dans le domaine de la santé
comme la france le reste de l'europe vit
une période économique sombre l'italie
notamment qui a sorti ses premiers
chiffres avec un pib en recul de 4,7
pour cent au premier trimestre c'est la
baisse la plus forte enregistrée par le
pays depuis 1995 c'est donc l'ensemble
du pib de l'union européenne qui
s'effondre -3 8% pour la zone euro et
ces chiffres ne sont qu'un avant goût
car il reste désormais à mesurer les
effets du confinement sur le pib pour
avril et une partie du mois de mai
notamment pour les états qui ont grondé
confiné en dernier une situation de
force majeure qui contraint la
commission européenne a présenté un plan
de relance il y aura à coup sûr un
équilibre entre subventions et prêts
c'est une question de négociations entre
états membres pour trouver un mélange
équitable entre eux prêts et subventions
les deux ont des avantages et des
inconvénients vous connaissez les
arguments en faveur de chacun ils ont
été présentés ce soir de façon très
constructive
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique les
états unis ont renoué avec la récession
après plus d'une décennie de croissance
l'oncle sam a enregistré une chute de
son pib de 4 8%
tous les indicateurs sont en baisse ce
que reflète désormais les 26 millions de
chômeurs que compte le pays pour aider
l'économie à se relever
washington a débloqué 660 millions de
dollars de prêts non remboursables aux
pme à condition qu'elle concerne leurs
salariés dz coûteuse mais obligatoire
pour survivre au coït 19 et à une crise
économique il faudra juguler en europe
comme aux états unis